you're very calculated in the way where
you know how to survive yes and did that
come from being in abusive relationships
because I can only imagine that you had
to do whatever you had to do to survive
in the worst possible yeah no that
didn't that didn't teach me about
calculating if anything that was just me
not having any self-worth hmm so that
was a different story
what taught me how to calculate was
watching everyone around me as I grew up
and who was successful and who wasn't
that's what taught me people from the
outside would look inside can't believe
you kept going back you were being
beaten yeah why did you keep going back
it's I don't know it's just you lose
yourself your sense of humanity you
don't even feel human anymore so you
feel like you have no rights and then
there's a part of you that feels like
you deserve it and it took me having my
son and having something happen with my
son there for me to say no my child
will not go through this I've heard that
from other women that have been I would
kill you baby before my child ever goes
through this right now we're in the
midst of madness with with Johnny Depp
and Amber her nursing he abused her on
several occasions I mean why now why are
you doing now why didn't you tell them
and if it's true then so you don't
believe her
no I'm not saying that I said if it's
true then do what you have to do why
didn't you tell the first time because
there were there were several and
because uh because that wasn't my focus
my focus then was getting out and
getting my life and taking care of my
kid I didn't intend on writing a book
about my life that was not even in my
head
you